hi Steve thanks so much for joining us
at after words today and congratulations
on what's quite an achievement thank you
I really first of all didn't start the
interview off saying I really enjoyed
the book
it read like a novel I mean it really
read like nonfiction in places which I'm
sure that as the writer you encountered
some of that feeling as well and I know
as a reporter who's dealt with Exxon
Mobil a good chunk of her career how
difficult it probably was to to probe
this company so let's kind of start
there why Exxon Mobile how did you come
to this subject me know that you looked
at Getty Isle previously in your career
but why this company and how was it did
how did it differ from some of your
other subjects like the bin Laden's
mm-hmm you know it's and it's just it's
an interesting to me it was an
interesting journey because as you point
out I mean I started out as a business
reporter on Wall Street when I was very
young and then I went abroad and worked
more on international subjects and after
9/11 I wrote about the origins of the
9/11 attacks in 20 years of American
covert policy in Afghanistan in this
book ghost wars and then after that was
over I thought you know I want to keep
writing about America and the world
after 9/11 this sort of asymmetric
strange groping that we had as a country
to understand what the attacks were
about what they meant for the United
States what our relationship with the
Middle East was and that led me to the
bin Laden's which was a book intended to
be about Saudi Arabia and its
modernization and how complicated it was
for this generation of oil shock boomers
that Osama belonged to to come of age in
the 70s when the Kingdom was just awash
and wealth and they had to all go out
and buy identities in the world and one
of them became a notorious terrorist and
the others all moved to Florida and so
forth and so that interested me and when
I was finished with that project I
really wanted to write about oil and
American power in the post 9/11 context
and so I started out actually the
project didn't begin as a book about
Exxon Mobil it began as a book about
oil and geopolitics I wanted to
essentially take the prize the book by
Dan Jurgen that had inspired me as a
young man long time ago and updated you
know I sort of thought of the prize as a
great work of nonfiction about the era
of oil that was an era of expansion and
discovery and what I wanted to do is to
write a book about global oil in the era
of limits and constraints and climates
and the rest of it and so I started out
and on that kind of open framework and I
got about six eight months into the
research and I thought to myself I
really need a subject here I need a
company and once I came to that
conclusion then for an American audience
I thought ExxonMobil was the only choice
so I sort of backed into them as a
subject and I didn't quite realize what
I was getting into when when they were
sort of forced upon me at least in my
thinking as a subject is I didn't know
how close they were how difficult they
were to report on I just thought they
would be a normal corporation and I also
didn't understand that much about their
distinctive internal culture so a lot of
the three and a half years that remained
was about discovering what ExxonMobil
really was and during the course of this
reporting the BP Deepwater Horizon spill
right at all were you at that point like
you know I picked the wrong [ __ ] well
mixed feelings I joked to my journalist
friends there must be a word in German
like schadenfreude that describes what
journalists feel when other people
suffer but you get an ending to your
book and I thought well this spill the
catastrophe of an environmental disaster
on that scale even though it wasn't
Exxon Mobil's responsibility it did
provide a kind of contextual bookend for
the Valdez spill which is a sort of
origin story Forex for modern Exxon
Mobil it's a story they tell themselves
they tell themselves the story that they
were scared straight by the Valdez so
that they reformed themselves and a lot
of who they are traces to the reforms
that that's started with that accident
so I thought well the the horizon and
Deepwater Horizon accident could be a
bookend at one stage what I was
wrestling with how to make this book
more specific I did consider a dual
narrative of ExxonMobil and BP and my
regret at Deepwater Horizon was maybe I
should have done that but looking back
on it it would have been too much
reporting I would never have gotten
underneath the surface if I hadn't
concentrated on one corporation so let's
talk about that that's really an
interesting point I mean starting the
book out with Valdez and to be honest
making it new I just in their narrative
I thought made it new and then ending
with with the Deepwater Horizon disaster
in the Gulf of Mexico in April 2010 as a
person that really delved into I know
you read a lot of the transcripts from
the Exxon Valdez incident did you see
any parallels do you because I did a
little bit as a reporter I didn't cover
about these I was it was young man I did
cover Deepwater Horizon and in your
description of Valdez and and and
Exxon's response to it I did see some
pare it almost seems like BP took a page
a little bit out of their playbook did
you see that at all as you were as you
were seeing their coverage of BP
definitely there were definitely
parallels I would have a couple you
could probably list even more than to
come to my mind but I fear the come to
mine are that in the decade running up
to Valdez there were warning signs that
Exxon was not operating in a consistent
manner in a way that that would give you
the highest possible reinsure
reassurance that such akatosh
catastrophic accident could not take
place in fact in the decade before the
Valdez Exxon cut 80,000 out of 180,000
employees they reorganized their entire
safety department their entire
environmental department and you know
obviously the fact that a tanker captain
with a drinking problem who had DUI
arrests was still in his job making more
than $100,000 a year in nineteen eighty
nine dollars that's not the Exxon Mobil
you would expect today so so there was a
there was a series of warning signs that
culminated in the accident the same was
true at BP I mean I don't know what you
would say but I had the impression from
people in the industry that bp's record
as a weak operator and you know the the
texas city plant the OSHA record the
fact that they basically had a culture
and a
strategy that emphasized financial
engineering at the expense of operating
discipline was pretty well known in the
industry and I sort of came to the
conclusion after talking to people for
three or four years that if you had
called up people in the oil industry on
the morning of Deepwater Horizon and
said to them the following thing has
happened who do you think the super
major is that was operating that
platform that you would have gotten a
strong you know majority for BP at that
point so so that was there the second
parallel was the preparation for
actually mitigating the disaster you
know in both cases there were a lot of
paper plans saying we can handle this
and then the reality was they were not
at position to do so right and and then
the the kind of public relations
narrative and learning how to deal with
all of the communities and traumas I
think probably BP had the benefit of 20
years of learning about corporate crisis
management at Exxon you know in those
days 89 this whole philosophy of how you
communicate and immediately go up on
television telling people you're gonna
make things right and so forth that
wasn't as well developed as a strategy
in Exxon's day but anyway no I agree I
think the aftermath strikes me more than
and then what happened before that both
of the disasters in terms of you know as
a reporter after the Deepwater Horizon I
mean BP had gobbled up like every expert
on any kind of we mean you couldn't find
a blowout preventor expert to save your
life right that wasn't on VP's payroll
and there's that there was that I think
the the the control that emanates
through this book it's um
I think emanated after BP in terms of
kind of controlling the message
controlling access to people that could
independently talk to reporters about
what happened and very technical subject
again um so you go everywhere in this
book I mean you globe to the word and
you also tackle numerous environmental
issues from global warming to obviously
the spill at sea at a tanker to to leaky
underground storage tanks lusts is what
the EPA calls them and MTBE which I
my early career in upstate New York -
the risk of phalates all would have
connections to this oil company because
it's integrated in controls oil from
cradle to grave how did you how did you
pick out the anecdote so this is a
company that goes back to standard oil
days there there's a treasure trove and
as a reporter I know it's difficult to
use that sifter and which nuggets you're
gonna pick so how did you pick out the
anecdotes for this book yeah so I
started out with a map once I chose
ExxonMobil as the subject I basically
looked at the map of where they owned
oil and gas and I just basically asked
myself as a reporter what kind of world
is this why are they there why are they
there and then I became interested in
traveling across that map because as you
pointed out earlier they're they're a
closed subject they they were not
excited to learn that I was doing this
book they didn't volunteer to be written
about they handled my enquiries in a
professional way but they didn't really
cooperate very much I think maybe they
would say that relative to some projects
they cooperated more than usual but from
the perspective of the ambition of the
book while it was helpful everything
that they offered it was pretty limited
so I basically had to go outside in and
so once I started with this outside in
process I started with the map and so
the first year I traveled a fair amount
out into the field where they operated
tried to understand their role in the
world their sense of themselves as an
independent sovereign how they operate
on the ground why are they in some of
these benighted countries learning about
their reserve replacement challenges
learning about why equity oil in weak
states had sort of evolved as part of
their portfolio and so on then I came
back to the United States and I thought
well I have a pretty good first draft
sense of how they operate abroad but I
really need to concentrate on their
Washington strategy and their lobbying
and political strategy so I then turned
to the tools that you use as a reporter
to go outside in in the United States
which is basically lawsuits and
disclosures so I had filed Freedom of
Information Act requests for all the
overseas work but to get at the
Americans subject I basically looked at
all their lobbying this
and it mapped those out too and said
okay what are they lobbying about and
Val AIDS is an example of something that
popped out of that I said what are
phthalates why are they lobbying on
valid and in the summer of 2008 they
were like all over that subject so it
was it was really the data that
basically said okay there's got to be
something here and then just to finish
on the lawsuits you know they get sued
by everybody over everything and so you
know it's a great tool of reporting to
be able to look at civil litigation
because in those cases records and
testimony are produced even if Exxon
Mobil's policy is never to give
interviews their executives have to
testify in these cases if they choose to
contest them so I was looking for cases
that told structural deep stories that
were points of entry into the
corporation and one I found was this
gasoline spill in Maryland where I
realized searching the litigation
records started with MTBE and then
fought my way down and and I finally
realized there was a huge trial record
around what had been one of the largest
gasoline spills in a in an area that
depended on fresh groundwater supplies
through aquifers so it was a
particularly dangerous spill in an
environmental sense and it had gone to
trial and the trial was over there was
this massive record of testimony by
Exxon Mobil executives plus documents
that had been produced and it was just a
gift I went straight into the retailing
and downstream division of Exxon Mobil
through this trial record in a way that
I could never have done through
interviewing so opportunistic is kind of
the short answer for how you choose
these subjects they you just keep
looking on the map and then suddenly you
see a way to tell a story so one thing
that's interesting though is despite how
broad they are and and in terms of
geography and in terms of subject matter
the lesson I think is is the same over
and over again which is is you I think
it also comports with the public's
perception of ehsan' which is this
company that is rigid that is
all-powerful that you don't want to mess
with didn't put for the cloak wheelie so
I guess did anything that you came
across surprised you or kind of fit
outside of that narrative because it
seems to me the book all the stories
kind of come
back to that in different ways you're
right in each each ones that has
different kind of take on it but in the
sum of its parts is this image of this
company that really comports with what
everybody kind of in their gut feels
yeah they are who they are and they and
the reason that that it's true across
settings that the same kind of
decision-making and the same kind of
culture and and insularity rigidity or
they might say focus consistency is
present in Indonesia and Equatorial
Guinea and suburban Maryland and the
Washington office is because they have
constructed a global system and global
policies that that are so unified and so
codified and so distributed down all of
their channels of operation that I think
more than any corporation I've ever
encountered as a journalist everyone who
works there gets up in the morning and
is reading off of the same playbook you
know it's almost like a military
operation or a sports team that's
exceptionally well organized around the
same playbook and I and I think they're
kind of self-conscious about that
military metaphor they you know they
they're unusual among corporations in
that everyone who's at the top grew up
together if you took the top 100
publicly traded corporations the United
States and you chose say the top 40 jobs
at each of those corporations and you
mapped who the people were you would
find that there would be a significant
number of people who came from a
competing company laterally late in
their career as an executive they moved
over or they came from another industry
as a marketing specialist and they they
came in with reforming ideas and so most
corporations are informed at the top by
at least some outside perspectives that
ExxonMobil everybody comes up from
college graduate school you know if you
were selected for management tracking
you know you grow up together over 30 or
40 years and let's you know it's like
the Marine Corps you don't become a
Marine Corps general by having a
successful career at IBM and then
deciding you want to go where two stars
on your shoulders you grow up together
as a cohort you share a common view of
the world so what you observe about as a
reader of the book which is that whether
it's a lawsuit in Venezuela or a civil
war an end
Asia or a gasoline spill in Maryland the
stories all seem to end the same way
just sort of enforcing their will and
then there's a reason for that that's
their system that's who they are but
then late late in the book and I think
that as a person that's covered energy
and environment for as long as I have
this surprised me you get into hydraulic
fracturing which is now all over the
news the Interior Department actually
today is going to put out some rules for
fracking on public lands and you almost
an agreement I'm wrong but you almost
make the case that that corporate
philosophy gave them a blind spot when
it came to hydraulic fracturing and it
was even more surprising because you
make an amazing point and actually
remember this this is like page 600 that
Rex Tillerson as a young engineer at the
company actually was using the technique
and so do you think in that one case in
the fracking case that corporate
philosophy of of what's manage our risks
let's make sure we make a certain return
on what we do hinder them from from
tapping into what is now this huge gas
boom huge economic opportunity in this
country with natural gas well they were
slow but they're they're often slow and
then they're decisive
once they decide they want to go in a
direction so they get to places late and
then they buy their way in that's their
pattern so they've never had a great
reputation as the world's greatest oil
and gas discoverers I'm sure they have
some wins and they probably have a you
know story they tell themselves about
their successes in exploration but the
and and they have some but by and large
their strength is financial and
operating strength so they have more
cash than anybody else they have more
discipline about choosing opportunities
so generally if they fail to discover
something for themselves they can buy it
that's what they did with fracking so
they had been trying to develop a
natural gas strategy as conventional gas
emerged after 2005 and 2006 increasingly
looked like a real opportunity and they
were going out and doing the kind of
land games and buying up leases putting
it together one patch at a time and
trying to build something but at their
scale
for them to be a player they needed to
come in big and so they bought XTO in
2010 now I one of the things that's
interesting to me about the fracking
story was exome then now they're the
largest producer of unconventional if
you've got forty billion dollars that
you can lay down you have become the
largest and almost anything and but
what's interesting and I wonder what you
think about this because I think of
climate as as a challenge of climate
legislation carbon pricing as an
analogous strategic challenge that
they've faced in an earlier generation
where they dealt with resistance to
their investments and they're sort of
thinking with a pretty aggressive
strategy now fracking is not just a
business challenge it's not just a
geological challenge it's not just an
engineering challenge it's also a
political challenge because there's an
enormous amount of anxiety building up
in the country about some of these
fracking techniques and their
environmental consequences their land
use consequences the unknown are you
going to induce earthquakes in places
that didn't previously have them now
if ExxonMobil becomes the poster child
of a rigid very corporate very kind of
stiff and profit driven approach to
these challenges then they may
strategically have a problem over time
can they actually adapt themselves to
the to the kind of trust building and
political coalition building that will
prove durable or will they take their
systems approach our way or the highway
and you know sort of end up defeating
themselves in some respect they could
end up with a tougher public response to
fracking and they would otherwise get if
they were a sutler
well they align themselves with with
with the other companies that are doing
this they don't seem in some cases and
you've touched on this in the book that
they're the odd man out yeah they're
kind of pursuing what they want to
pursue and doing it their way and and
and are taking no punches and and maybe
no excuses for it which brings me I had
a conversation this morning with Ellen
Jeffries who I know you
the name well who's that chief spokesman
for ExxonMobil and I asked him about the
book and I want to get a reaction to his
reaction from you which I think you'll
find very ExxonMobil asked but I'm
paraphrasing here and he basically said
essentially how we see the book is it's
telling the story of Exxon Mobil's
commitment to safety and community it
may not be a popular or fashionable
these conservative approaches but we
think these are good qualities of a
company of this type and so basically I
said today I said to Ellis and Whistler
saying that's how we are and take it
yeah saying that obviously does not
surprise you with the course of this
book and they actually have read it as
you probably know I'm for more people
ExxonMobil the poor through this book
what is your response to that well I
appreciate that he's you know dealing
with it in a professional way and and
you know they're they basically about
media about journalists about political
opposition about environmental groups
they basically stay in their channel and
that's what he's doing so he's saying
you know we are who we are that's
essentially their strategic position now
sometimes we are who we are feels a
little bit like a defensive crouch and
that kind of gets to this fracking
question can can you really be have the
the sort of strengths of their operating
system which are considerable I mean
their safety driven they're you know
they're focused on operating excellence
and so forth they have a pretty good
reputation in the business as project
operators I mean if you and I were the
code dictators of oily stand and we
wanted someone to develop our oil and we
wanted the project to come in on time on
budget and to get paid early you know we
would definitely entertain their
PowerPoint presentation because they
they have a record of a project
management that's that's good where
where they get into trouble is where
they extrapolate these kind of operating
systems this rigidity into political
affairs you know the human factor
community relations things that aren't
you know things that are suppler that
are made up of community they're made up
of social change and and their own
record for example as a social entity
themselves as a corporation on the
promote
and women on diversity on responding to
the kind of world that we live in it's
not great you know you know he can say
that these conservative values are out
of fashion but we think that they're
that they're powerful you know that's
that's fine if you're talking about
crossing your T's on safety at the
workplace but can they really succeed
with the strategy in a world where
they're so closed to the changing social
makeup of say you know who's who's the
educated workforce in the United States
anymore it's mostly women it's it's more
and more diverse and if you work at
Exxon Mobil and you go home to your
family Thanksgiving dinner and you say I
work at Exxon Mobil and half your
cousin's you know suck in their
breakfast and disdain or or worry you
know that's not a winning strategy over
30 years either so somehow this
something's got to give I think I'm not
sure that they think that though let's
go to that because that's one of my
questions too is that it seems to me
that kind of we are who we are and take
it or leave it we really don't care what
anybody else thinks about that has that
backfired on them I mean it seems that
that that could have been a force to
cultivate more distrust than distaste
and helps make them as you say in the
book you know public enemy number one
that points in their history
yeah well it's I mean it's a it's a
great question and it kind of
complicated one I mean I think one of my
goals as a reporter was to try to
understand as best I could and to think
about what is it like to be so unpopular
does it matter
because they're sort of view their
default view is doesn't matter just like
the Allens statement to you you know we
are who we are but in truth I think
there are consequences
part of it is talent and recruitment and
retention and there in the real world a
world of the Arab Spring generation you
can't get away with just being disdained
by everybody in a map and hold your
technological and scientific edge how
are you going to do that scientists are
ornery independent minded people you
know some of them may be willing to
adapt to the economic rewards of a
career at place like Exxon Mobil but not
if it doesn't really feel like an open
and changing place a you know B if you
know if you only have one way of living
in the world and problem sets and risk
management are getting more and more
diverse you you know you can't afford to
go into communities that already have a
presumption that you're evil it shows up
at jury trials I mean you know yes they
can appeal all these verdicts billion
dollar verdicts and eventually get them
knocked down to zero but do you really
want to go into every jury setting and
basically know that you have to overcome
a presumption that you're evil I mean I
so I do think there are consequences and
you but the problem from their
perspective is let's think of a way out
of this box one of the things they did
was they said our well let's go back
through history is there some Golden Age
of oil industry popularity that we could
model as a basis for a more winning
strategy and the answer is no so it goes
to the basic question of if we are who
we are
is there really a way to communicate
about that that will change anybody's
mind you know Vincent that just put
putting lipstick on the pig as they say
in the PR business shouldn't we just be
straightforward shouldn't we have a
strategy that just says we are who we
are again and again and hope that that
allows enough people to come into
engagement with us to to realize our
interest so that's what they've done
basically cuz you know it's me I was
starting to our business writer John
Fahey in New York he's an excellent
energy writer and he's Oscar winning in
her book and we were talking about I
said hey you know I'm interviewing Steve
any questions for him and he brought up
Apple mmm as Apple is now more valuable
than Exxon Mobil right and it's all so
secretive there's also thin-skinned
right but apples cool yes you say I work
on the iPod everyone's gonna cry bring
that question full circle I mean do you
I mean it's kind of a two-parter which
is do you think Exxon Mobil's strategy
has kind of tarnished the rest of the
oil business and kind of people
associated with Exxon and everybody and
Big Oil is bad
do you think it's spread to other
companies over the case of Apple it
seems gonna be kind of thin-skinned and
controlled and secretive and and and
still be really hip and cool people come
like you yeah it's really interesting I
mean one of the things you if I went
back and looked at what are the top five
corporations in the United States from
like say 1949 to the President and
Exxon's distinct because they're always
on the list and the companies around the
horizon five right they're always in the
top five where the companies in the 50s
that were number one or two US Steel
that don't exist anymore so now you look
at today Apple and Exxon Mobil are one
and two ten years ago it was Exxon Mobil
and Walmart Microsoft is always in the
mix but you look out 50 years further
which one do you think is more likely to
still be around Exxon Mobil or Apple so
that's one question
I read the jobs biography by Walter
Isaacson it's a terrific book and it is
striking both how completely different
and how similar Apple is to Exxon Mobil
I walked away thinking what a country
only the United States could produce
both Apple and Exxon Mobil because on
the one hand you know Apple is a
completely California bred creative
sixties lecture I mean in the book
Isaacson reports that Steve Jobs used to
go into interviews and ask serious job
candidates if they had ever done LSD in
the hope that the answer would be yes I
mean if Exxon Mobil they're going the
job intervention they say you please you
know take this cup and provide us a drug
testing and report your paper copy yeah
so on the one hand they're very very
different and on the other hand there
are these similarities that you referred
to they're both closed systems they both
have a command management they both are
driven by a desire to control their
environment I mean Steve Jobs
desperately wanted to control every
element of the customers experience
every element of the design and they
both were not good partners they didn't
really believe in partnership they you
know they believed in the advantages of
total control and that makes them
secretive because it's really the
secrecy that follows the desire for
control not not secrecy as an end in
itself and so it's it's fascinating the
other point about Exxon Mobile and it's
in pop unpopular and they came to think
about every time was you know most big
industrialized democracies because of
the nature of our energy economy they
all have big state oil companies so
there's two talent
there's any an X and X and X of Mexico
BP and yes in the industrialised West
most of those states have privatized
them but even BP and Royal Dutch were
partially state-owned as recently as the
1980s so but only in America do we have
ExxonMobil is our state-owned oil
company they're a much more coherent
coherent expression of our national
energy policy than anything the federal
government does that's for sure
and they're just as powerful relative to
the state as to talas de France and
maybe you know even more so and yet only
in America would we have a state oil
company that lives in opposition to the
state in which it resides I mean Rex
Tillerson recently told scouting
magazine that his favorite book is Atlas
Shrugged by Ayn Rand now that's a sort
of touchstone for libertarians and it
suggests an attitude of sort of
skepticism let's say generously toward
the government that is peculiar now the
equivalent company in France or Italy or
even in Britain would be they would have
all gone to the same universities as the
president United States they would be
buddies they would there would be an
interlocking a sense of world view and
maybe even as with total they would work
arm in arm with the French government
abroad in order to secure to Taos
interests and so forth but you know this
country
we're skeptical of our government and
the last iron is we're also skeptical of
concentrated power so here in ExxonMobil
is an institution with enormous
concentrated power whose chief executive
reads a book that is basically about the
dangers of concentrated power and
celebrates it so one of the things that
came up I think is really interesting it
goes to what you just said about their
influence on Washington we was actually
really fascinating because out of one
side of their mouth they say they really
don't want to play ball and yet they're
playing ball harder than some others in
some cases they have direct lines for
instance during the Lee Raymond days to
dick cheney and call on washington when
it helps them and their business
interests to get him out of geopolitical
conflicts but one thing i found
interesting is you talk it talks in here
about politicians getting it
I think it I put down the page number
and it's it's even more more apt today
yeah here it is
so it says its quote from Tillerson the
global free market for energy provides
the most effective means of achieving US
energy security this is that their
theory that it doesn't really matter
where you get oil from as long as you
get more oil and you put it in the
bathtub
we'd have more supply in the global
market the nationality of the resources
of little relevance energy made in
America is not as important as energy
simply made wherever its most economic
right yet ExxonMobil has carried that
message for a long time and it goes back
to Raymond and the Tillerson they're
obviously communicating it to a lot of
the Republican allies you make that
point that they're lobbying is is
heavily skewed to the Republicans out of
the party yet that's not the message
you're hearing from petitions today
we're hearing a very almost resource
nationalist approach to us semantic
energy production I love it as whele and
Exxon Mobil is not to embarrass to join
in that even rightful philosophy I guess
it's kind of shocking to me and I'm
asking for an explanation here is is how
can this all-powerful company with huge
influence not have changed that
political discourse to make it actually
more adhere to the facts of of how
global oil market works yeah I think
also engage in it as you say yeah you
know well I think they've had influence
on sort of elites in the United States
educating they've carried out this very
intense education campaign to try to
bring what they call informed
influential and government around
government and media into their
conversation about how the global oil
markets actually work but you know most
politicians don't have time or interest
to study in depth these kind of
complexities and and one of the
executives I interviewed told me that
that one of the world leaders who
understood it best how the global oil
markets really are integrated in liquid
and nationalism though it can be
relevant is is not what it seems energy
independence was Tony Blair and and this
executive is talking until the
polarities
you know you're one of the few people
who runs a government who actually
understands how the oil markets work you
know isn't that a shame and Blair
supposedly said something like what you
really wouldn't want all the other
politicians in the world to know because
then they'd just think they could do
something about because what's happening
right now in Washington on both part in
both parties you know both parties are
trying to kind of get a handle and show
that they're reacting to gasoline prices
when in effect they really have very
little power over gasoline prices
exactly but this question of what are
the benefits of energy independence or
what is in energy independence mean even
though the way it's used in political
campaigns is is frustrating because it's
so sort of divorced from the actual
subject matter but there there's a real
subject there that's important and
interesting and it's and it's changing
an exxon mobil's position in the quest
for energy independence is also changing
because basically while it's true that
being a net exporter or a net importer
of oil is not really the right way to
think about energy security because
everybody's a price taker doesn't matter
whether you're selling or buying the
price is a global price that's not true
of natural gas which is more regionally
priced and there's there's been some
evolution toward a global integrated gas
market but we're not there yet
and so in the United States if we have
onshore natural gas that's really cheap
for a long period of time that could
make a big difference to the economy it
could reduce our costs of manufacturing
it could change our energy mix in a way
that's favorable in response to climate
change and while you know being a net
importer or a net exporter may not
matter in some of the way politicians
talk about it it does matter to our
balance of trade to the amount of
dollars net net that we send abroad to
unfriendly regimes versus those we keep
it home to reinvest so you know if we do
shift toward more energy independence as
it's called even whether we call it
nationalistic language or economic
language there will be advantages
they're just not the same they're not
the advantages that politicians often
I know one of the other current events I
was thinking about in reading this book
was going back to the days of iron ass
lee raymond's
which i thought was a brilliant chapter
um that's not has kind of shunned
alternatives for good reason they're an
oil company in their business is oil so
you know they don't want to really hear
about hydrogen for cars or you know you
know electric cars whatever what have
you and they also get an excellent point
which is one of my frustrations is an
energy reporter of how people mix the
electricity side energy production with
transportation right right but I
couldn't help think there's places in
the book where Lee Raymond talks into
the ear of Alan Greenspan and Alan
Greenspan is on the hill and basically
saying Lee Raymond's speech right if on
Solyndra which is the solar company that
has grabbed headlines and railed if Big
Oil is behind that given that their
animosity towards kind of renewables and
the subsidies renewables require did you
see any evidence of that reduce to the
government to making this bad loan and
or not making a bad loan but but fanned
the flames of the criticism on the loan
went back well I think the American
Petroleum Institute which is the trade
group in Washington they they're a spun
up communications machine that that
seizes every opportunity and their
political allies did the same thing but
yeah I mean I I think the underlying
question about alternatives and Exxon
Mobil is it's you know they're a
corporation they can pursue whatever
business strategy they want the question
is as a country you do we want to create
subsidies and incentives for a shift to
alternatives of the sort that the loan
program that that ended up with Solyndra
provided and why would we so you know if
you look at it we've been talking about
how everybody in the country shares an
interest in the lowest cost energy
possible consistent with a sustainable
environment that's the that's the
dilemma right so you want the lowest
cost energy but you also want to achieve
your environmental goals now we may not
define those goals the same way but if
you talk about a rat
good shift and costly shift from cheap
coal and oil and gas to more expensive
but cleaner renewables you better have a
good reason to do that now the reason
that's the most compelling in the world
we live in today is climate and if you
so if you believe as I do I find 97% of
mainstream clients scientists and their
warnings and their findings entirely
convincing so so if you believe that now
you have a reason to endure short-term
costs for long term gain but if you want
to try to convince the public that
there's no risk then the case gets much
harder which is why Exxon Mobil's
resistance to the basic findings of
climate science after Kyoto was so
pernicious and so damaging because there
is a residue of doubt in the public
about the validity of of climate science
and the climate threat and scientists
tell us there shouldn't be such doubt
now why is there well these interested
parties funded a campaign a
communications campaign to plant that
doubt now of course you know the
American people are adults they're
entitled to their own opinion but but
that campaign clearly was influential
and also let's talk about that cuz I
thought that was a really interesting
part of the book because you make and I
don't want to put words in your mouth so
but to me it read as it's almost as if
Exxon invented that strategy that Exxon
was a company that really was in the
business of playing this scientific
doubt you know funding research during
which it was great I love that part with
the NOAA scientists on the beaches of
the Prince William Sound 12 years after
the spill and they're being tagged by a
yacht of exxon mobil hire and scientists
who are want to know what they're up to
and and criticize their methods event
really kind of cast doubt on a science
showing that the oil was still there
after all the years and that tactic now
seems wrap it in our political culture
as a reporter that pays us attention
closely you're now look seeing it you
know where the science of climate change
you know it's a theory it's a theory
accepted by many many people and it's a
valid theory now you're seeing it in
areas that were almost locked solid I
mean there's
there's politicians now on the floor
talking about the linkage between smog
and asthma there's there's people that
are questioning the cost-benefit
analysis of the EPA when it when it
drafts regulations do you I mean do you
look at the exons kind of tracker her
than that and be like hey Exxon is
responsible for that kind of that kind
of tactic cuz it seems now it's a very
common one like let's not talk about the
regulations which is attack the subject
the regulations are trying to address
right no I think I think that they they
have responsibility for some of that and
that they really were a distinctive
investor in that specific strategy after
Kyoto because look when the Kyoto Accord
z' were signed there were there was a
lot of opposition to them in the United
States and in the industrialized world
on economic grounds on fairness grounds
some of it was about as the science
really you know that urgent that we need
to impose these costs on ourselves there
were but there were a lot of different
groups that opposed Kyoto for those
economic and fairness reasons but
ExxonMobil was very unusual in my
judgment in the aggression that they
brought to the science part of the
campaign really funding groups whose
principal activity was to communicate as
non scientists a narrative of doubt
about what was emerging as mainstream
climate science and and that is I'm
afraid you know a tactic that is more
and more present where science and
public policy intersect and it's
dangerous because our whole progress as
you know an industrialized democracy
depends on an honest argument about
science and and you know the public good
and if we're going to have especially in
these fractured media times you know a a
completely polluted argument where the
public the even the public trying to act
in good faith isn't sure who to believe
about what we're gonna end up you know
damaging our society now this book makes
clear that Exxon
is almost an impenetrable fortress as a
company but when you get to climate
change and I'm biased here because I'm a
climate junkie
it really seems that this really scares
them there's this great until then there
was only one unexpected development one
Black Swan intervention that could shift
the curve of rising global oil demand
which obviously Exxon enjoys those are
my words a decision by governments to
limit greenhouse gas emissions by
heavily taxing or capping the use of
carbon-based fuels I mean is that a fair
estimation I mean that this that issue
because of what it could do to do oil
right is what really really kind of had
them shaking in their boots I think it
got their attention I think it was a
combination of how it was a rare
existential threat is the reason we were
talking about before they had a stab
they had overcome the previous systemic
threats to oil production in the world
which were spills and environmental
damage and the seepage of oil into water
and drinking supplies and an air
pollution all of that had been more or
less brought into a sustainable compact
of regulator and regulated and and they
had themselves adapted they had accepted
the validity of these environmental
goals when it comes to spills and air
pollution and so forth and they had
adapted themselves it imposed costs on
themselves in order to build the
sustainable compact so just at the
moment when they've got cruising speed
on all of the other environmental issues
that arose in the first three or four
decades of the oil world now comes this
other existential more abstract global
challenge to the primacy of fossil fuels
in our system now so I and I so I think
that was one factor Lee Raymond
personally as a trained chemical
engineer and as a very direct and you
know determined chief executive decided
that he would just say what he thought
and and use Exxon Mobil's resources to
prosecute his views that most corporate
chief executives even if they had that
personal conviction would not have acted
as aggressively as he did but that's who
he was so that was a second factor you
know I the book
reflects I interviewed Raymond and I
asked him at one point you know surely
you could have handled the costs of
modest carbon pricing legislation right
I mean look at your cash flow look at
your profitability why resist it I mean
you've adapted to air pollution
regulations you've adapted to spill
regulations you you run pipe you pride
yourselves on your compliance with
regulatory regimes that impose costs on
you for making the oil industry
sustainable in a political and
environmental sense why not just adapt
to these regulations and you know I
found his answer not that convincing he
sort of said we thought the costs on the
whole economy would be too great that
would break up America's economic
progress and so forth but I
there was a visceral reaction to Kyoto
that ExxonMobil had that was kind of out
of line with their actual business
interests I would understand if you're a
coal company and you see Kyoto coming
you see a price on carbon coming Urich
and this really could be existential but
the oil industry because of the mix of
gas which is a low lower footprint and
they had an opportunity to adapt to this
in a more forward-leaning way and
frankly the European companies saw that
and their publics were already there and
they moved with much more depth as I
thought
now another idea that I found really
interesting in the book as you raise it
a couple times at least twice I can
remember but you're not hearing it at
all right now in Washington when I talk
about gasoline prices me is regulating
gasoline prices like we do like
electricity and how electricity all want
the lights on it's kind of a public
right and how we regulate that right
because if it got out of control and
prices soared people wouldn't be able to
turn their lights on
why aren't we hearing that more when it
comes to gas and should we be hearing it
more as a solution that after something
the government could do well I think
it's a very serious question and the
reason we don't hear more about it is
because in fact the political arguments
we have during campaign seasons about
gas prices are just theater they're not
very not serious arguments so there's no
no reason to paint a serious policy
question and make them
but the point you make is really
important which is you know you flip on
a switch in this room and you generate
power and a company profits from that
use of power that company is a utility
that is regulated by a Public Interest
standard in every state or jurisdiction
separately but the Public Interest
standard is there and that's our history
with the provision of electricity we
think it's so important so fundamental
and so inescapable that we require the
profitable companies that provide it to
meet certain public interest standards
and to be accountable to the public for
their performance and we cap their
profits often now in Exxon Mobil's case
they're a global company they're out
discovering oil and under ice and in
seas and so forth nobody's gonna
regulate them in the public interest in
that scenario but in the provision of
gasoline it is a similar utility
function and in fact you know if you're
a commuting construction worker us to
drive 60 miles a day and your pickup
truck to a job site you go to the pump
you've got no choice you've got to put
it in and whatever price is there and
you can't understand why you have no
accountability and no control over that
kind of trap that you're in and I think
it's a serious it's a sort of an
accident of history that we treat the
provision of gasoline as entirely a
free-market function without any public
interest oversight basically some taxes
and some environmental regulation but we
treat public electricity as a public
utility in many other countries they
organize things differently I don't know
that there's an easy way to fix this but
ExxonMobil recognizes the problem
because their unpopularity arises from
the fact that their brand name is stuck
on all these pumps where people are
angry I mean no no business basically
deliberately tries to put its customers
into a position of pain while they're
staring at their brand right and you
make the point in the book that that's
actually the only way they're visible
yeah it's there because otherwise people
really don't understand the whole oil
process I mean people aren't watching
ExxonMobil drilling holes in the ground
or deep offshore or you know and
Equatorial Guinea as you traveled in the
book I mean all we really see of them is
you know the tiger in the tank and you
know their brand name and there's a
board meeting that's described in there
when lee raymond toward the end of his
career says to the board
for all the reasons you just listed why
don't we just get out of the gasoline
business why don't we take our signs are
all empty Warren why don't we just be
like DuPont nobody gets up in the
morning saying DuPont is evil but DuPont
is a huge industrial corporation
whatever its strengths and weaknesses
its invisible by comparison now one of
the other points that you make later in
the book and it's in reference to this
session about energy policy and kind of
the lack of a u.s. energy policy or at
least a coherent on and made the point
earlier conversation that really exon is
the u.s. policy that politicians have
kind of struggled with that because at
the end of the day it requires the
public to make some sacrifice mm-hmm and
they really don't want to step there
they didn't want to go there because
once you once you go there people start
to say hey I don't want to do that I
mean every poll we've done at The
Associated Press on energy always says
well yeah we want we want you know to
reduce the risk of climate change and we
want clean air but we really don't want
to have our electricity bills go up as
to do that
right which is a consequence of any kind
of market same and also a consequence of
a carbon tax that trickles down to the
consumer and change your habits so to
kind of turn the tables a little bit as
excellent as the bet but the bad guy I
mean it seems to me that our inability
as the public to make sacrifices makes
us more beholdin to these companies that
we don't like right no well I think that
there's there's truth in that and you
know it's interesting I was trying to
think about this question of the price
that people would have to pay to to
address climate change in particular and
I think well nope no public at any era
wants to volunteer for higher prices in
their household expenditures our
politics shows that where the public saw
a threat to living generations if they
thought their children were more likely
to get asthma or develop respiratory
disease because of air pollution that
was unaddressed or that their children
were likely to more likely to be exposed
to cancer as a result of pollution in in
water supplies that people were willing
to pay a price whatever the price was to
protect their living generations
from that danger the problem with
climate is that it's over the horizon
and the dangers are serious but abstract
me and so yeah you may be motivated to
think my grandchildren twig and children
in a world where there's three degrees
Celsius higher than we have now
and rising seas but you know it's not
the same and and so this cost-benefit
equation is part of the problem and the
other thing about what you observe is
that there isn't a government in the
world where politicians don't want to
make gasoline as cheap as possible I
mean it's like it's like bread and
circuses I mean it's it's it's two
chickens and it's 250 most of the world
governments over subsidized gasoline
just so that they don't have to deal
with the public's anger about what the
gas would really cost if they let market
prices rule and so here we let market
prices rule up to a point then we add a
bunch of taxes for remediating
some of the environmental costs and try
to reduce driving and so it's expensive
already and so you go to politicians and
you say I have a plan to make gasoline
even more expensive and you're not gonna
find a big caucus lining up I mean that
quote from Obama was in a edit board I
think somewhere in California where he
says that you know as a result of
cap-and-trade gasoline prices haven't
necessarily skyrocket I mean that has
been recycled right he's being honest
right exactly they're gonna have to go
up well if you if you put a price on
carbon but but that has come back to
bite him you know over and over and over
again on subsidies let's talk about that
you mentioned subsidizing gasoline Lee
Raymond obviously has a disdain it's
very clear in the book for the crutch
that renewables need to be economic and
and ExxonMobil as a company seems to
loathe any kind of crutches you know but
there's crutches that oil has I mean
this is a huge debate right now in the
Congress you know and and the president
is pushing to end tax breaks that oil
companies have enjoyed and they make
these enormous profits why should they
continue to have them did that come up
in your conversation with Raymond at all
because it doesn't seem to come out in
the book very much and it's kind of kind
of like it's kind of pointing out kind
of their a little bit of hypocrisy I
think yeah well I sort of felt
stalemated around that
subsidies question I just I still feel
like I don't quite know what to think
about it I don't know what you think
about it but you know there basically
there are some tax breaks that oil
companies alone get through interpretive
kind of appeals about what how the oil
industry in specific terms is located
but most of these allowances are
manufacturing allowances they just
happen to be manufactured by gasoline as
opposed to tractors or something else
and so okay we can say let's
discriminate against the oil industry
because they're making too much money
people are paying too much gas let's
eliminate those subsidies and let's
rebate it to drivers who have to drive
to work and can't get us okay that's a
reasonable public policy but to just say
that that these are subsidies only for
the oil industry I'm not sure that
that's actually even correct so I I
don't quite know what the right I know
it's great politics I get that reason
why this keeps happening is because it's
great politics for both sides and
there's no danger of these laws actually
passing right then you can say whatever
you want about but I think it's a
serious question as to how you should
restructure American energy policy
impose great I'm all for imposing
greater costs on ExxonMobil I'm sure
they'd be delighted to hear that I I
think they should be doing more to
facilitate a national energy policy goal
of addressing the serious risks of
global warming by moving as rapidly and
economically as possible to a new energy
mix but I don't think that stripping out
manufacturing subsidies and then not
repurposing those funds to achieve that
national goal necessarily is very
persuasive so I think what the first
thing to do is to put a price on carbon
and put it in a substantial and
predictable way so that all companies
can respond to it and we can get moving
in this direction we need to go we have
a few more minutes and I can't I have to
get to Canada mmm cuz I found them I
found I found I found the Canadian
section later in the book really
interesting again in light of it is very
clear from what you write that prior to
Keystone XL
excellent was infuriated with the u.s.
approach to Canadian imports but because
they're from the tar sands and as you
and I both know energy-intensive to
extract huge amounts of greenhouse gas
emissions just in the extraction process
but now I guess the Keystone happened
obviously after the book was was written
that kind of goes right to the heart of
that you know Obama rejects Keystone
pipeline
environmentalists were furious about it
because of the climate change issues I'm
assuming that you would you would
conclude that Exxon is also as furious
as it was back then oh yeah I think that
they're they're just they don't quite
know what to do about the politics of
the Keystone pipeline because in their
book it is such a it's so irrational
that they can they almost can't overcome
their own sort of indignity about how
disconnected the politics of the
pipeline is from the underlying
questions of climate change regulation
they'll that tar sands or the oil sands
and their role in that and and the
global oil markets I mean basically this
is the Keystone pipeline is a
continuation of the things that made the
Matt earlier that's described as
basically just trying to attack the
problem look even the environmentalists
if in would admit I'm sure that could
enact a universal price on carbon as the
basis for addressing climate change and
the dangers of global warming they would
but they failed to do that they couldn't
get a bill through Congress so now
they're looking to understandably to
keep their issue alive by looking for
opportunities to call attention to the
problem and to and to keep challenging
the status quo so they've chosen the oil
sands because it's available not because
it's their preferred and solution to
global warming but they say they've sort
of made it an example and correct and
and basically they're trying to leverage
the unpopularity of pipelines in general
and the not in my backyard politics that
are common in the United States to kind
of keep this issue moving and you know
from Canada's perspective
I'm sure it's aggravating
from the oil industry's perspective it's
definitely aggravating because a
pipeline that would otherwise make
economic sense is being punished for a
campaigning reason not because of some
you know policy framework overall and I
mean that the truth is that if Keystone
isn't build and it will be built I think
I mean the citizens elections over
either the President Obama is going to
reverse the judgments that he's made to
get himself through this campaign in one
way or another or the Romney
administration will build the pipeline
that's my you know that and $3 against
your cup of coffee at Starbucks but
that's my prediction but in any event
even if Keystone weren't built the
Canadians would just export it to China
okay it's it's it's actually not that
big a big a deal from the greenhouse gas
emissions are gonna happen
either way unless Canada changes its
policy towards the the sands yes well
thank you very much I really enjoyed the
conversation and congratulations again
on the book thank you very very much